hello and welcome to my garden today we
are looking at the onions that I have
planted here in containers I started
these from seed way back in January
February and we are now nearing the end
of July and these onions have all
flopped over as you can see that's a
sure sign that they are almost ready to
harvest I've left them laying here like
this for a week or so try to refrain
from watering them so that they dry out
a little bit
if we just zoom in here you can see
these are my yellow Globes
they have flopped over the necks are
soft they've started to develop kind of
a skin around them here
so I think it's time to pull them out
and let them dry out and cure and
hopefully we can store them for several
months
so hopefully I can get a nice supply of
these cured and can store in a cool spot
in my basement
so I'm going to start off by pulling
these onions and storing them in my
garden Wagon here so I think this wagon
here is going to be a perfect spot for
them to cure off for the next week or
two they'll get lots of air flow we can
store this in a spot out of the direct
sunlight where there's lots of wind and
hopefully this will be a great spot for
them to cure
so my onions aren't super huge but it's
it's an improvement from last year for
me personally
especially these yellow Globes here
they turned out really nice
pretty happy with those
so I'm just going to
pull them all out here
lay them out in my
wagon
I do have some Walla Wallas also in this
tub on this side I don't know
they could have been a little bit bigger
I know Walla Wallas are normally a lot
bigger than that but nonetheless
this is what I got
I'm pretty happy
so just kind of finger around them
gently pull them out so that they come
out with all their roots
so picking onions obviously a very easy
thing to do
definitely the yellow Globes are looking
bigger than the Walla Walla
so I don't do a lot of in-ground
gardening other than my potatoes
and I think these have done well
for container gardening
it's been very easy to maintain
pretty easy to pull weeds out of these
containers
I think I gave them a fertilizer once or
twice in the month of July early June
so these little tiny ones here will
probably get eaten up pretty quickly
and in this tub it's all Walla Walla
onions
I tried to keep them spaced out so that
they you know could get as big as
possible
I did a little spooning around them
early July when they were starting to
develop
try to thin them out by picking the odd
ones that were too close together
again not a bad size these will be great
just you know one for a meal when you
need an onion these are going to be a
nice size to cook with
we cook with a lot of onions
pretty much on a daily basis I'm adding
onions to my cooking
so I'm excited to have a good Supply
that'll hopefully lasts me
you know till the end of this year
I just think that's beautiful it's like
a bouquet of beautiful onions
so I don't have a cold room per se in my
basement we have in-floor heat in our
basement so don't have a cold room set
up down there unfortunately we didn't
think about that
when we built our house 20 some years
ago
it's a beautiful nice cozy basement with
that floor heat but there is one corner
of the
the space and empty bedroom now that uh
the core heat doesn't seem to be working
very well never did so that room is
actually extra cool it's in the north
west corner of the house it doesn't get
a lot of direct sunlight in that room so
I think that's going to be uh my new
cold room this winter so we're going to
hopefully get some shelves set up in
there to store potatoes and onions
and my last container here is the ruby
ring onion so these are a red onion
again we've been picking these a lot and
eating them fresh
so this is my ruby ring onion Harvest
here
so there is my onion Harvest for 2023
not bad for a little garden
so I'm going to leave these in this
wagon to dry and cure I'll push them
over in a spot that's kind of out of
direct sunlight it gets lots of airflow
if you want these stems here to kind of
dry up
maybe some more skin to develop around
that and that will help protect it and
keep it fresh so that it will store
longer over these next few months
so I've already done some harvesting of
my garlic a few days ago that I didn't
do any filming of but this is what I've
gotten so far so this is a hard neck
garlic variety that I planted last fall
here in the in the ground some of the
cloves were from my previous Harvest
from last year that I replanted
somewhere I purchased from the store so
how you know that they are ready to
harvest is when you look down at the
base here and you can see that some of
the leaves are starting to yellow and
die back usually two to four leaves
is a sign that these are ready to
harvest
and like the onions you should try and
dry out the soil and not water them for
a week or two before you harvest just so
when you pull them out you don't do any
damage if they're too wet so I have my
soaker hose that runs through the garlic
here into my lasagna garden bed so I'm
running it every day or two so I didn't
really dry it out in some of these spots
like I should have
and then as you can see when I tried to
pull this one out it kind of ripped away
the roots because it was a little too
wet and soft so this one will probably
have to be eaten right away it might not
cure as well
but just to show you give you an idea of
the difference between a garlic clove
that's well watered and some that aren't
as well watered this one was growing
right next to my soaker hose all summer
same with that one there as you can see
they're a lot stronger and bigger so
watering definitely does make a
difference this is probably the biggest
garlic clove I've ever grown pretty
excited about that one
so the spot that I picked to grow garlic
in is right next to some of my Choke
Cherry bushes here which you can see are
almost ready to pick
and I'm dealing with a lot of suckers
from the choke cherries coming into this
area
so I've been kind of battling that I'm
not sure if this is the best place for
the garlic
I do want to try next year to grow
garlic in containers because
that's how I do most of my gardening I'm
just not sure how they will make it
through the winter in a container if the
cold weather that we go through you know
the minus 30 35 degree cold in the
winter can be pretty brutal on any
perennials that you're trying to keep
alive so we'll see how that goes we can
also plant garlic in the spring early
early spring so I might do that as well
but it's so easy to just put in the
ground keep it watered very little
maintenance and it's a great
Easy Storage over the winter garlic is
something that like the onions we pretty
much are cooking and eating every day so
the more I can Harvest and store myself
would be great
so I just want to show you how I'm just
trying to kind of work around the clove
here with my hand
kind of pull away that dirt you want to
be able to to pull it out without doing
too much damage to the roots
again it's a little bit
pretty moist right here because I've
been watering through here but I'm going
to try and pull it out without
doing too much damage you can use some
kind of a potato fork or I'm just using
my
hori hori knife here kind of get under
and then gently pull
there we go
the garlic
something else you want to remember to
do if you're growing garlic is to in the
usually early July the garlic starts to
send out these what we call Garlic
Scapes so they shoot this out it's got
seed in it so the garlic is trying to
self-generate some new seeds so that it
can you know grow some new garlic so you
want to make sure that you are watching
for these Scapes in your garlic and
harvest them off that way the energy
will go back down into the bulb and the
garlic will keep growing and be bigger
if you leave these on you know a lot of
the energy is going to go into
self-seeding so you want to just watch
for those and make sure you chop them
off they're usually kind of a spirally
circle and they make a great item to
cook with you can chop them up and put
them into your cooking they have a nice
garlic flavor as well
so this is the Garlic Harvest you know
it's not a huge huge amount of garlic
but I think it's a great
amount for two people my husband and I
are the only ones living at home now so
this will definitely last us a while
um next year I planted the really double
down maybe and grow a lot more garlic
trying some new methods in containers
maybe try growing some in the spring
and see which works best for us
so this hard neck garlic is is a good
variety for you know our growing zone
here in the Zone 3 Canada
used to do really well
so for now that's all I'm gonna do just
chop back the uh the tops I'm just going
to let them dry
so that some of that dirt comes off
naturally let them develop a little skin
layer cut back these roots
and get them ready for storage so thank
you for joining me while I harvest my
onions and garlic out of the garden so
I'll be storing this Wagon in a spot
kind of out of direct sunlight it's
getting lots of wind we haven't been
getting much rain so I'm not too worried
about them getting wet we'll leave them
to dry for a week or two and then
hopefully they'll be ready to store in
the basement thanks for watching hit
that like button leave me a comment
don't forget to subscribe so you don't
miss out on future videos coming to the
channel